bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week end votre magazine dédié à vos
sorties et vos loisirs
au sommaire de ce numéro après sa
fermeture hivernale le parc france
miniature située à elancourt se prépare
à sa réouverture des animations
commencent dès ce week end
le corps est à l'honneur à la
commanderie des templiers sa
représentation son étude médicale et ses
mouvements sont au coeur de deux
expositions et nous recevons en plateau
jean pierre fat fiat membres de vélo ski
l'association vous propose une randonnée
familiale pour découvrir la circulation
douce à saint quentin en yvelines jeudi
et à l'heure à elancourt le parc france
miniature ouvre donc ses portes ce
week-end et pour en parler nous recevons
en plateau marionnettes bien bonjour
bonjour vous êtes responsable de la
communication et du marketing de france
miniature
alors les équipes ont travaillé jusqu'à
la dernière minute est-ce que tout est
prêt on va dire que tout sera prêt les
équipes sont encore à pied d'oeuvre
cette après midi le soleil et a vécu
tout pour les dernières finitions on va
dire mais on sera prêt demain matin 10h
à l'ouverture
la saison précédente avait des nouvelles
animations il y avait un champ de
fouilles y avait une grotte est ce que
elles sont toujours présentes
alors oui elles sont toujours présentes
là l'évolution du parc france miniature
va dans le sens de plus d'interactivité
plus d'occasions pour les enfants de
deux touchés de découvrir et de
pratiquer tout un tas de choses et cette
année on ré ouvre effectivement avec
cette grotte préhistorique avec le
chantier de fouilles avec différentes
occasions sur le parc de pouvoir
pratiquer et découvrir et être vraiment
acteur de sa visite aux puces dans sa
grotte les enfants pour une fois sont
autorisés à dessiner sur les murs
exactement c'est ca france miniature
qu'on peut dessiner sur les murs comme
les hommes préhistoriques mais au moyen
de tablettes interactives
il a assez
ses activités autour des monuments mais
il ya aussi des animations l'an dernier
nous en proposer c'est toujours le cas
pour cette année ce sera toujours le cas
tous les mois on va aborder une
thématique différente on ouvre avec le
printemps autour de la ferme et on
accueillera dès dimanche un partenaire
qui s'appelle la ferme rose qui est une
ferme pédagogique itinérante qui sera
france miniature dimanche pour présenter
le mouton on va attendre les moutons
avec eux et puis on va récupérer de la
laine et puis faire une petite
initiation atelier filage de la laine
les enfants pourront repartir avec un
petit bracelet de l'aisne ces ateliers
se font librement sur place ça
commencera dimanche après midi
et donc on invite nos visiteurs à venir
se présenter près de de nos animateurs
pour démarrer les ateliers il ya un âge
particulier à avoir pour faire ces
ateliers c'est vraiment adapté à partir
de 5-6 ans après venir voir les petits
moutons ça commence même dans la
poussette pour les ateliers s'est
entraîné mais ce qu'il faut quand même
s'inscrire quand on arrive comment ça se
passe il y aura pas besoin d'inscription
les gérera au fil de l'après midi on
conseille aux visiteurs de venir au
départ de leur visite nous rencontrer
pour qu'on puisse leur expliquer à quel
moment suis plus opportun c'est une
volonté de france miniature de dépasser
les monuments aussi de proposer des
activités ludiques aux enfants disons
que c'est l'occasion de proposer des
moyens d'aider tant des changes
supplémentaire pour les familles on se
rend compte que dans nos vies où tout
court c'est agréable le week-end de
passer du temps ensemble et de se poser
un petit moment
en plus de la promenade pour pratiquer
et découvrir quelque chose avec ses
enfants ou ses petits enfants puis cette
année la réouverture a une saveur un peu
particulière parce que 2016 france
miniature fête ses 25 ans 25 ans cette
année effectivement le parc a ouvert en
1991 alors beaucoup de choses ont évolué
ont changé des monuments sont arrivés
d'autres sont repartis
on a accueilli ces nouvelles activités
pédagogiques et interactives pour faire
de ce parc un lieu où vraiment on
s'amusait où on expérimente des choses
et puis pour fêter ses 25 ans on a tenu
à associer tous les jeunes gens qui
fêteront leurs 25 ans ou qu'ils ont fêté
cette année en 2016 seront les invités
de france minimes
donc il suffira de se présenter avec un
succès suffit en quête de naissance en
91 pour pouvoir visiter gratuitement
france miniature toute cette saison et
toute la saison les saint quentinois
seront aussi mis à l'honneur avec leurs
maris ce intéressant préférentiel tout à
fait le nouveau territoire élargi de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pourra
bénéficier sur présentation de la même
manière d'un justificatif de résidence
d'un tarif de -25% sur l'entrée pour
permettre aux familles ou aux grands
groupes qui habitent le territoire qui
voudraient venir profiter de cette
sortie -25% à partir de demain et
jusqu'à début juillet juste pour faire
un point sur france miniature qu'est ce
qu'on peut y voir ce qu'on fait on a
beaucoup parlé des animations on parle
de monument mais quel monument est ce
qu'on peut trouver aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui du nord au sud on va
rencontrer le beffroi de douai on va
passer près du mont saint michel on peut
s'arrêter à paris entre le stade de
france est la tour eiffel le château de
versailles bien serait présent et puis
en descendant vers le sud on va
traverser l'auvergne en passant à côté
des volcans on va traverser des petits
villages typiques comme le village de
conques par exemple et puis sur les
bords de la méditerranée puisque les
fleuves les mers et les océans sont
représentés on pourra retrouver saint
tropez où les arènes d'arles par exemple
en une journée on visite la france à
échelle humaine
c'est ça tout une toute une balade pour
découvrir sur cinq hectares 117 monument
faire un petit passage dans un espace de
huit attractions pour se divertir et se
défouler et voilà un joli voyage en une
bonne demi journée voire une journée
c'est familial c'est pour les enfants
c'est à partir de quel âge votre site
alors c'est vraiment un site tout public
tout le monde y trouve son compte le
petit enfant qui a aucune référence de
patrimoine va s'amuser avec les trains
ou les bateaux ou les petites voitures
qui circulent pour reconnaître les
monuments il est vrai qu'à partir de 6 7
ans ça commence à être vraiment
intéressant de pouvoir leur transmettre
des messages importants
merci mariale et de verdad venu en
plateau pour découvrir ou redécouvrir
les monuments français à échelle humaine
france miniature ouvre donc ses portes
ça
10 9 avril à la commanderie des
templiers le corps est à explorer sous
toutes ses formes à travers l'histoire
de la médecine mais aussi ses
représentations corps tangibles et corps
en images ce sont deux expositions à
découvrir jusqu'au 24 avril
sephora namani vous en donne un
avant-goût corps tangibles et corps en
images des expositions en une pour mieux
appréhender le fonctionnement du corps
humain
la première réalisée par escales des
sciences propose un voyage anatomique
qui conduit des représentations antiques
du corps à son approche médicale
contemporaine grâce à l'imagerie la star
de l'exposition c'est ce vidéo mapping
la vidéo mapping qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un type de vidéos où on travaille
de manière très précise
la projection et on a plusieurs niveaux
en fin de discours et de d'information
projeté donc là par exemple vous pouvez
voir sur le corps vraiment ce que l'on
voit avec chacune des techniques
d'imagerie médicale c'est-à-dire ici il
ya quatre techniques d'imagerie médicale
qui sont présentés les rayons x la
résonance magnétique les ultrasons
radioéléments efflorescence en quatre
actes l'expérience se poursuit avec
l'exposition corps tangibles et quatre
oeuvres numériques comportementale
invite le visiteur à jouer avec l'ombre
de son corps pour créer en direct des
visuels géo qui s'affiche sur écran pour
ce faire on utilise des éléments de jeux
vidéo des kinect
l'un fait précis on expérimente on le
vit on est à là on est vraiment dans des
oeuvres projetées
ce sont des grands systèmes de l'image
projetée immersive dans lequel le
visiteur peut interagir c'est à dire
qu'il passe dans un espace est là en
fait son image captée et elle est
traitée au niveau artistique dans la
projection on voit son image qui est
alors interprété en marge de cette
exposition des mini ateliers permettent
de découvrir l'intérieur du corps en
parallèle de ces deux expositions
l'atelier des sciences et les
itinéraires poétique de l'agglomération
vous proposent deux rendez vous liant
corps et poésie le samedi 9 avril à 14
heures ils gaudin pour être rhapsodes en
résidence à saint quentin en yvelines
déclamera des textes dans une approche
sensorielle et
cible et si vous souhaitez prolonger
l'instant poésie deal gaudin l'artiste
vous invite à partir de 15h30
toujours le samedi 9 avril à le suivre
au coeur des expositions pour des
lectures impromptues
vous pourrez notamment découvrir le
rapport entre le patient et son médecin
à l'espace richaud de versailles c'est
dire aux taniguchi qui met à l'honneur
il est l'un des auteurs japonais les
plus appréciés des lecteurs européens
la première traduction française de
l'homme qui marche fête cette année ses
20 ans
un sujet de sephora namani il est l'un
des mangas cas les plus connus en france
et en europe avec une trentaine d'albums
jirô taniguchi
vingt ans déjà que son oeuvre est
traduite en français depuis l'homme qui
marche sorti en 1999
en quarante ans de carrière l'artiste a
su conquérir un public
intergénérationnel
grâce à la diversité des thèmes traités
il a commencé comme plein d'auteurs
japonais en faisant son apprentissage
auprès de m et en et en apprenant à
décliner des genres assez
traditionnellement identifié comme le
western comme le polar comme le récit
des aventures de puis petit à petit il
est allé vers des sujets de plus en plus
introspectif de plus en plus
contemplatif de plus en plus personnelle
et qu'il est un peu le sol au japon
aujourd'hui à aborder de cette manière
une contemplation à orienter vers des
thèmes tels que les racines l'origine la
famille ou encore la nature la richesse
de son oeuvre lui a valu différents prix
tels que le prix al far du meilleur
scénario 2003 et le prix du dessin 2005
au festival d'angoulême une influence
occidentale dans son dessin illustré
notamment au cours de sa carrière par sa
collaboration avec moi bus ce qui est
caractéristique dans le travail de
taniguchi c'est que cet homme très tôt
et c'est rare chez les japonais s'est
intéressé à la bande dessinée au final
il est fait la démarche d'aller voir ce
que c'était et cela tout de suite touché
ça ne m'a inspiré et son travail est le
produit de s'inscrire à la fois le
produit de quelqu'un qui est un japonais
donc qui a un style vraiment empreint de
ce qu'il ya de nippon chez tous ces
auteurs japonais mais également avec une
influence occidentale
au cours de l'exposition un documentaire
lui est consacré il accompagne le retour
de jirô taniguchi dans sa ville
japonaise d'origine totori on poursuit
cette week-end avec notre nouvel invité
l'association vélo ce qu'il vous propose
de partir en randonnée avec elle pour
découvrir la circulation douce à 50 ans
les villes et versailles ce dimanche
jean-pierre fiat bonjour nous à nous
membres du bureau de l'association
la randonnée est ce qu'elle est
accessible à tout le monde déjà elle est
accessible à tout le monde dans la
mesure où on sait bien faire du vélo
qu'on s'est frayé comme ça voilà qu'en
se faire du vélo mais sinon elle est
ouverte à tous le moment de partir
depuis dix ans donc vous viser un public
familial un public familial tout public
on ira tous publics et donc c'est une
une balade qui va durer deux heures et
demi à peu près pour faire 10 15 km avec
dans l'ensemble c'est assez plat il y a
une petite montée mais qui monte et qui
sera fait à pied
vous vous proposez donc un parcours
d'une dizaine de kilomètres vous partez
de la bibliothèque cinq ans exactement
et quelle est la suite la suite donc
nous ils ont nous irons vers le bois de
saint cyr où on appelle le bois de
satory on suivra donc il ya un chemin il
ya des chemins donc on suivra ce chemin
on aura un point de vue un endroit un
point de vue sur le château d'eau de
château de versailles qui est vraiment
exceptionnel
ensuite on descendra au plan d'eau des
suisses et on ira vers fera un petit
tour et ensuite on reviendra par
saint-cyr et vous concluez le manière ce
rendez vous sympathique d'un pique nique
qui aurait lieu donc là sur le plan
l'espace vert de l'université vous
donnez un parcours aux participants ou
l'association encadre la randonnée en
restant groupe et on encadre d'une
certaine façon mais chacun reste
responsable et chacun doit respecter le
code de la route quand c'est nécessaire
pour des questions pratiques
il faut s'inscrire avant de venir c'est
mieux ça nous permet de faciliter un peu
là l'organisation
ce n'est pas strictement obligatoire et
donc faut s'inscrire sur la messagerie
vélo ski @ free.fr lobello ce qui ne l
eau est ce qu on y voit là une animation
comme ça c'est le plaisir de randonner
mais on parle de circulation douce vous
souhaitez aussi faire découvrir aux gens
qu'on peut se déplacer sur 50 on est
mené sur versailles en vélo ou alors on
organise ses balades à thème ces débats
là n'est pas un thème si on a déjà
organisé des balades sur guyancourt
c'était le thème c'était les rues avec
des noms qui portaient des noms de
femmes célèbres on a été aussi
à la colline de la revanche et c'est
donc c'est pour montrer que on peut se
déplacer en vélo facilement dans la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines et
dans les alentours
voilà donc c'est un des objets de notre
de notre association est de ces balades
sont faites pour montrer la faisabilité
de ces de ses déplacements
vous essaierez aussi les participants
peut-être à des règles de sécurité quand
on est en ville parce que on dit souvent
aux automobilistes de faire attention
aux cyclistes mais c'est aussi à lui de
faire attention
absolument voilà donc il faut d'abord
respecter le code de la route
avoir un vélo en bonne qu'ils soient
bien fort bien équipé en bon état qu'on
soit visible c'est à dire que on a des
des lumières quand la nuit qu'on ait
éventuellement un gilet jaune et il est
possible aussi et surtout pour les
enfants avoir un casque
ce n'est pas obligatoire mais s'est
fortement conseillé et ce week end
justement vous vous demandez aux gens de
venir avec quel type de matériel leur
vélo bien sûr à ce qu'il faut qu'il soit
équipé d'autres choses là vous parlez du
casque wii u peuvent prendre le casque
notamment les enfants les adultes c'est
à leur appréciation faites vous de votre
association ce qu'on la connaît
peut-être pas nécessairement est ce que
pouvait me déjà me la présentez vélo ski
c'est vélo ski ce vélo ce qui fait
partie d'une association francilienne
qui s'appelle mdb mieux se déplacer à
bicyclette qui est donc basée à paris
qui historiquement est une très ancienne
nouvel os qui nous avons une dizaine
d'années et donc nous sommes rattachés à
cette association pour faire la
promotion du vélo en ville le vélo
utilitaire
c'est à dire que les villes c'est qu'ils
bien de pistes cyclables de moyens pour
attacher son vélo en toute sécurité
voilà donc c'est la promotion du vélo
que je qualifierais utile dans la ville
c'est le cas sur 50 à se déplacer assez
facilement il y a des pistes cyclables
sur saint quentin il y a encore beaucoup
à faire pour faire un réseau qui soit
homogène qui permettent d'aller d'un
lieu à un autre dans les mêmes
conditions de sécurité il y à des
endroits où la sécurité n'est pas
suffisante il ya un cas particulier où
nous nous battons actuellement c'est la
rue qu'est celle qui est en cours de
réaménagement et houleux il n'y aura pas
il n'est pas prévu pour l'instant de un
aménagement spécifique pour les vélos et
c'est très dommage
c'est pour ça que vous multipliez les
actions on l'a vu là vous faites une
randonnée vous faites des ateliers aussi
oui on fait des ateliers
alors il ya une autre association que je
donne qui fait la réparation de vélo ça
c'est s'il ya un site s appelle vie
cycle est et on peut aller sur son site
lls incité qui lui permet on peut savoir
où au lieu ces ateliers de réparation
vous cherche à promouvoir auprès du
public mais vous vous rapprochez ans et
des élus parce que ce sont finalement
qui décident de la mise en place d'une
station
oui bien sûr et on a participé au rock
qu'on participe à tout quand on peut et
quand on est invité toutes les études
notamment on a participé au schéma
directeur de la ville nouvelle
on a participé au plan local de
déplacement et donc chaque fois que nous
pouvons donner notre avis nous le
donnons en tant que utilisateurs etc
c'est à dire le fait que tous nos gens
font du vélo au quotidien et donc voit
les choses un peu différemment par
rapport aux aménageurs peuvent donner
les conseils en tout cas plus faire du
vélo en ville ne nécessite pas d'être un
très bon cycliste nous en faire bien sûr
tout le monde qui s'est faite toute la
personne qui sait faire du vélo peut
faire du vélo il ya 2 jours 7
ce problème de la sécurité entre les
voitures qu'on a sur la gauche et les
voitures qu'on a sur la droite qui sont
stationnement
ils peuvent à tout moment ouvrir une
portière et ça ça peut faire des dégâts
merci jean pierre fiat détenus en
plateau pour nous parler de votre
attention de votre association
et si vous voulez randonnée en famille
et en vélo avec l'association vélo ski
rendez vous dimanche 10 avril à 10
heures devant la bibliothèque de
l'université versailles saint quentin à
guyancourt
comme chaque semaine les équipes de la
librairie du pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux vous donne une lecture
paulina miettes s'intéresse cette fois à
abraham et fils de martin winkler
l'ouvragé vous plonge dans l'histoire
d'abraham et de son fils france âgé de
neuf ans c'était fini je te parlais du
nouveau roman de martin winckler qui
s'appelle abraham et fils alors on va
suivre l'histoire d'un jeune père qui
arrive avec son fils donc le père
s'appelle abraham son fils s'appelle
france et tous les 2 débarque dans un
petit village en beauce lui il a obtenu
un poste de médecin et donc on va on va
découvrir l'histoire de ce père et de ce
petit garçon visiblement ils viennent
d'algérie les petits garçons n'a jamais
connu sa mère il sait qu'il ya eu un
accident mais son père n'en parle jamais
et lui laisse pas lui poser trop de
questions
donc voilà on va suivre l'histoire de ce
père et ce fils et à travers l'histoire
de la maison mon histoire du village et
des questions que le petit garçon se
pose et qu'il va poser à son père on va
aussi s'interroger sur l'histoire
française
on est à l'époque du général de gaulle
donc toutes les grandes histoires tous
les secrets cachés durant l'occupation
ressurgissent à cette époque là et voilà
c'est le petit garçon qui nous raconte
sa et la maison dans laquelle il habite
c'est vraiment un très très beau roman
il ya toujours cette histoire de
médecins comme martin winckler et
médecins voilà c'est très beau c'est un
médecin de campagne qui emmène son fils
dans son histoire et toi ce qui l'a ému
c'est plutôt la relation voilà entre le
père et le fils aussi tant avec la
maison qui la maison ensemble dans la
maison elle est très important mais ce
qui est vraiment très bon en fait c'est
donc la relation entre le père et le
fils mais surtout
la curiosité et la nike finale de ce
petit garçon qui osent se poser plein de
questions et qui obtient des réponses
soit par son père soit dans ses lectures
soit en interagissant avec la maison est
ce qu'il ya des petits passages secrets
donc on retrouve beaucoup de l'humanité
comme on a l'habitude de voir un peu
avec 20,4
cette perception très fine c'est un très
beau moment on continue sur cette ut
week end l'émission dédiée vous sortez
vos loisirs avec une page cinéma cette
semaine syrie la date de l'espace
philippe noiret des clayes-sous-bois
vous invite dans les halles aux dessous
les salles obscures en écoute son coup
de coeur
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film louis ferdinand céline avec denis
lavant et géraldine paillasse 1948
accusé par la justice française d'avoir
collaboré avec les nazis
louis ferdinand céline s'est exilé au
danemark avec sa femme du 7000 tonnes in
du jeune écrivain juif américain qu'il
admire le soutient avec ferveur le
rejoint au fin fond de la campagne
danoise avec l'intention de tirer de
leur rencontre un livre de souvenirs de
la confrontation entre les deux hommes
personne n'en sortira indemne le film
relate de façon admirable les tensions
qui habite cet homme au combien
singulier excellent médecin est quasi
fou géant littéraire d'une intelligence
supérieure et monstrueusement antisémite
le film est quasiment un huit clos qui
brique par l'ambiguïté du jeu des deux
acteurs principaux
la mise en scène sobre et quasi
théâtrale donne un côté fascinant à
cette oeuvre cinématographique
coup de chapeau comédien denis lavant
qui interprète magistralement le rôle de
céline louis ferdinand céline est à
découvrir cette semaine à l'espace
philippe lauret mais qu'est ce que c'est
la littérature
contraire de la vérité on poursuit avec
vos avis sur les sorties de la semaine
c'est au micro de camille lambert et
guillaume le squer c'était pas mal je me
moi j'ai bien aimé était pas mal on
change d'époque mais c'est toujours les
mêmes les mêmes blagues
voilà ça change d'époque non c'est sympa
il ya quelques trucs drôles mais bon je
dis pas qu'on change de costume bien
bien bien bien subtile
beaucoup de monde il est donc une large
place à l'imagination
je trouve j'ai beaucoup aimé les
passages en reclus dans le vercors de
philosophes aux futurs philosophe
allemand ainsi qu'isabelle huppert qui
se ressource leurs contacts puis la
place pour le chat andorra c'est fabien
accuse environ aussi donc c'est
important c'est ainsi avant de conclure
notre page cinéma dernier rendez vous à
noter le signer cette d'elancourt
accueille samedi 9 avril à 18 heures
l'équipe du film fleur du futur d'eau
bravo da vous pourrez découvrir le rôle
des petits cycle de l'eau et de la
gestion des sols à l'échelle locale et
mondiale
on regarde un extrait la mauvaise
gestion de l'eau à l'ère industrielle et
notre modèle de développement
on finit par provoquer l'assèchement
mondiale des terres et de l'atmosphère
la modification de la surface de la
planète par les activités humaines
atteint un point critique qu'elle
compose du jazz ou de la pop brisa roché
propose des morceaux aux sonorités
puissantes et électroniques
elle est sur scène le samedi 9 avril à
20h30 à la batterie de guyancourt elle
était l'invitée de sephora namani lors
du kiosque du 6 avril où l'écoutent
je suis profondément américaine dans ma
perception des morceaux qui sont souvent
assez assez courtes sa c4 4 assez assez
pop
finalement ça c'est peut-être un peu
plus américain que le format français
qui suit les textes qui peut aller
ailleurs personne n'a encore entendu cet
album encore et à la batterie je vais
justement jouer avec mon groupe des
morceaux du nouvel album donc c'est un
moment on peut avoir un petit image de
ce que ça va être
et mêmes pour nous c'est tout nouveau
donc on est très excités 1
non
ban
cette lutte est venu
mais lui
oh
santé
et toujours le samedi 9 avril c'est la
22e édition de fréquence grenouille
comme chaque année les de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines vous invite à
découvrir le triton crêté une espèce
menacée particulièrement protégés sur
l'île l'événement est gratuit et débute
à 14h mais les inscriptions sont
obligatoires
et on termine notre 7,8 week-end avec de
l'humour le café de la plage à maurepas
accueille deux artistes
samedi 9 avril à 20h30 car la forêt
dénonce avec légèreté dérision toutes
ses petites manies de notre quotidien au
travail
anaïs tempère le breton elle vous plonge
dans un entretien d'embauché collectif
cocasses et déjanté regardez pour
réussir à optimiser votre temps planifié
délégués pour ça moi j'ai trouvé le bon
équilibre bon l'équipe travaille tout le
temps et moi jamais plaisant enfin
dernier point voilà j'ai oublié les clés
de ma maison dans la voiture ouais non
mais j'ai aussi oublié les clés de ma
voiture dans ma maison
d'accord sur wii à la présentation
d'entreprise présentation personnelle
qui suis-je un générique beaucoup je
pose la question alors je m'appelle
agnès claudio je suis arrivé dans
l'autre il ya maintenant neuf ans donc
simple stagiaire et je suis aujourd'hui
ni plus ni moins de la numéro deux de la
survie de ce magazine est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine en attendant passer un
excellent week-end